First of all,
one person can wreak an awful lot of
havoc.
There's absolutely no doubt about that.
And as we get more technologically
powerful,
that becomes even more relevant and
important and crucial.
You know,
one of the things that you said was that
we had to wake up because we are too
technologically powerful to be as
morally asleep as we are and that seems
to me just to be self evident.
That's.
Yeah,
for sure.
That's true.
We're,
we're,
we're half asleep with nuclear bombs.
It's not a good idea.
It's seriously not a good idea.
And so.
Well,
and then you might ask yourself too,
you know,
like what is the ultimate potential of a
fully developed human being and well we
certainly know that you have admiration
for people who are more developed rather
than less.
That's,
that just happens automatic or
resentment that.
But that's okay.
It's the same thing.
It doesn't matter,
but it's not like you can identify that
you can identify them and they're put
forward to you in,
in,
in drama and fiction and all of that
constantly.
So that's another form of moral
intuition.
You know,
you can read,
you can discern the wheat from the
chaff,
let's say.
And,
and so
the other thing that I was thinking
about it's worth consideration too,
is that,
you know,
and maybe this is,
maybe this is petty,
but I don't think it is.